I don't know if you follow what's going
on in China right now but some are
saying China's going through a real
estate apocalypse literally I mean think
about how competitive these guys are
some kids say Americans are the most
competitive people in the world however
did you know China has a city called
Tian du Chang that they built the exact
Eiffel Tower in that City they built a
strip just like Sean's Elise were in the
real estate that you buy in this city is
so expensive kind of like how it is in
France that's how competitive this place
is however China's got a big problem
something crazy just happened this last
month Country Garden Holdings which is
their biggest real estate company
developer in China that did 441 billion
ones last year just missed the debt
payment you ever missed a credit card
payment you were like I forgot to make
that payment who calls you the credit
card company they just missed a debt
payment you know how much it was just 20
million ones and they missed it and in
China there's all these cities called
ghost cities they have 65 to 90 million
vacant homes everybody's looking at the
data saying China's selling themselves
as they're doing really good but wait
till you see when we compare them to
another case study of another country
that grew as fast as they did you should
see what happened to them next if you
give value out of this video give it a
thumbs up and subscribe to the channel
do you remember earlier this year or
last year when Silicon Valley Bank or
signature or it was a couple other ones
that went out of business and others
came and picked them up because they
were rates were going up too quickly
they couldn't make their payments like
oh my God what is going on over here now
imagine if that happened to JP Morgan
Chase or a black rock because this
company we're talking about is not just
one of the companies it's the biggest
company in the real estate development
business so when you look at this chart
here from Country Gardens dollar bonds
slumped deeper to distress levels look
at the date of June middle of June you
see how it's around the 80 cents on a
dollar look where it drops to by the end
of July to around 10 cents it's nearly a
70 drop off in six weeks and you can't
make a 20 million one payment you're as
big as you are you can make that payment
a debt payment that's deeply concerning
and by the way outside of those guys new
home sales by China's 100 biggest
developers dropped by 33 in July from a
year ago when you look at the numbers
here this chart developer finance and
extend drops so can you see the black
the pink the blue and the yellow the
black being self-raised funds the pink
being deposit Advanced payments the
bluebeam personal mortgages and the
yellow bean domestic Bond look what
happened in the middle of 2021 right
there how how much it was peaking around
1.8 trillion won and look where it's at
now dropped to nearly 1.2 trillion won
in just two years again another reason
why a lot of people are concerned about
what's going on in China however let's
continue why does this matter because
more than 85 percent of China's houses
are sold through pre-sale up from 50 in
2005 which means mortgages begin months
or even years before buildings are
finished and by the way the reason why
this is important just last year in 2022
October there was a massive mortgage
protest in China nearly 100 plus cities
people coming out in WeChat messaging
each other saying why are we making all
these mortgage payments on a property
that ever Grande China ever Grande group
is not even making any progress on
they're not even building it but they're
taking our payments what is this all
about to the point where the government
had to get involved and say hey guys you
can't be doing this stuff if you're not
building it you can ask people to make
the payment so many people were
frustrated not trusting what they were
doing leading to this now this company
that's even bigger than ever Grande so
now the reason why this is important is
because in China most of the money the
GDP is tied to real estate very
different than other countries just to
kind of give you a comparison here's
what it looks like China's real estate
sector accounts for 30 percent of the
country's total GDP in U.S the real
estate sector is only 17 percent in
Japan is 11 even in Canada it's only 20
but in China it's 30 percent so what
does this mean that means if there's any
kind of movement in real estate they
feel it more because it's that bigger
piece of GDP let me take you a little
bit deeper on how much China believes in
their own stock market versus other
countries like America here's what the
numbers look like in China only seven
percent of population owns stocks while
roughly 90 percent of our homeowners and
to make that comparison in U.S in U.S
roughly 53 percent of the country owned
stocks and only 65 percent of Americans
own real estate were more balanced
they're not they're all real estate
nothing in stocks what does that tell
you we don't believe in stocks we
believe in real estate and not only do
they own one home 20 percent of folks in
China own two or more homes however they
don't believe in the Airbnb model like
we do in America they don't rent them
out because they feel it loses value
they like to keep it brand new so look
if you're running a business one of the
things that matters to business owners
is jet fuel you need jet fuel what's jet
fuel money you need money but today a
lot of business owners are saying Pat I
want to go borrow and get some money but
the interest rates are so high where do
I go one of the options you have is a
company called fund and grow funding
grows a great sponsor because they
understand how to help small businesses
get the funding they need even in
today's economy they offer a 12-month
membership that gives small businesses
an alternative to traditional funding or
Gathering investors they offer a way to
get operating Capital you need without
having to deal with the current tedious
and confusing red tape at Banks they
help secure credit up to 250 000 with
zero percent interest and all without
you giving up any Equity of your company
these guys have a great online
reputation with 4 000 reviews at 4.9 so
for you watching this funding girl has a
special Master Class where they teach
you five steps on how to secure 250 000
on loan and to learn about the stuff to
have a 500 discount for all the people
that are with valuetainment so if you
want to learn more about this go to fund
and grow.com forward slash pbd once
again fund and grow.com forward slash
PVD or go to the description you'll see
the link there so now you may ask and
say why did I only put the money in real
estate because if you look at the chart
since 1998 what you'll notice is the
average real estate sale price in China
every year has gone up literally if you
look at this pretty much every single
year it's gone up and they can't
necessarily say the same thing maybe
about stock market or other Investments
so they trust in real estate and by the
way when you think about value real
estate or expensive real estate what
city in the world do you think has the
most expensive real estate some of you
may say Beverly Hills right and how do
we really Define that math anyways
here's How We Do It Whatever the average
salary of a person in that city is to
the actual average value of a home for
example say you make a hundred thousand
dollars per year but the average house
value in that city is a million dollars
that's 10 times make sense look at the
most expensive real estate in the world
comparing you to the average income of
that City let me just show you this
chart hopefully this will make sense to
you when you look at this look we have
all the way at the top Beijing meaning
the average home there is 48 times the
average salary of the city that means
most people cannot afford to buy a house
in Beijing same with Shanghai same with
Hong Kong or Zhang Zan and then it goes
to London but look how much of a drop
off London is it goes from 40 drops to
22 then he got Bangkok Sao Paulo Rome
Moscow Seoul Paris Munich Tokyo then you
get to New York which is roughly 12 and
the same is with San Francisco so as
much as we talk about how expensive real
estate is in San Francisco and New York
it's almost four times more expensive in
Beijing Shanghai Hong Kong or zhengjin
now keep in mind that's all money you
may say well you got to figure out a way
to make more money or go to move to a
smaller City totally get it but there's
other kind of pressure there as well one
of them being social pressure in China
because the one child policy that they
had there's
33.59 million more men than women in
China in 2016. there's the Mother-in-law
economy that they talk about which means
what social pressure for men to go and
ask someone's hand for marriage hey I'd
like to marry your daughter they want
you to own a home in China if you don't
and another man does the family is
willing to give their daughter up to a
man with a home than one without a home
that's a lot of pressure for men in
China look there's a lot of Pros to you
growing fast but they say there's two
ways a company goes out of business it
grows too slow it grows too fast when
you grow too fast if you all of a sudden
don't have enough inventory or customers
there's a lot of problems there if you
cannot deliver on your promises things
can break people aren't happy so they
leave China may have the fastest growing
Urban is in a history of mankind when
you look at this data how they either
took regular areas that were Rural and
they turned into cities or people left
those areas to go into cities and
migrate into cities look what the
numbers look like from 1980 till today
1980 it was roughly 19.39 of the
population that lived in urban areas to
today it's
65.22 that's almost 50 in 42 years but
if you're looking from 2000 till today
in 2000 they were at 36 percent today
they're at 65. when you grow that fast
things are going to break and they're
kind of going through it today so so the
urbanization is just one of the issues
that they haven't grown too fast but
outside of that one of the problems
they're having right now is with
deflation so you know how in U.S we're
like oh my god look what's going on with
unemployment or look what's going on
with all this inflation that we have
what do we do raise the interest rates
once twice three four five oh you know
what inflation is gradually coming down
so the the FED has a way up cooling up
the economy or heating up the economy if
they choose so like when we went to a
128 month expansion that we we have an
economic expansion we lower the rate so
low that everybody was just borrowing
borrowing borrowing money so the economy
in China is kind of cooling up they're
kind of scared saying what is going on
people are no longer spending they're
hanging on to cash because they're
scared and they're not putting the stock
market so the economy has to figure out
a way to heat it up again in a fake way
so how do you do it make financing
easier lower rates start giving 25 year
loans to people above the age of 70 like
assuming they're going to live up to 95.
stuff that just makes no sense that's
kind of what they're going through right
now to get people buying again because
again they got 65 to 90 million vacant
properties someone's got to buy these
places so as if this isn't enough
problems and by the way if you don't
know the history of China China owns 100
of land like in China if you own a
property you may own the property but
you're leasing it from the government 20
to almost like 70 or 90 years you don't
own the land in China the government
owns the land in China or maybe it's
shared by the government maybe with you
but they own 100 of the land in China
kind of weird but that's what socialism
and communism does however the bigger
the problem they're facing right now is
the unemployment amongst the youth that
we're on 140 million folks between the
ages of 15 to 24 years old and look what
their unemployment looks like if you
look at this chart from 2003 till now it
shows it goes from 9.61 to 13.16 but if
you continued look how high that thing
goes in China all the way up to 21 of
kids and some young adults that cannot
get a job right now 21 obviously that's
also very problematic because if you
can't get your youth working what are
they going to be doing so obviously you
know if you don't follow the story in
China you may be thinking oh my God
China's crushing it they're going to be
passing up America very soon all this
stuff we've all said it right that we
felt for that this is what's going to be
taking place again there's two reasons
why companies go out of business you
either grow too fast you grow too slow
in this instance they're grown way too
fast and another country went through it
so the deflation cycle that they're
going through causes a few things one
consumption goes down people don't want
to spend money they want to save money
number two businesses cut prices
consumers expect for prices to go down
so they hold off with purchases business
businesses lay up employees and
obviously all of this adds up and the
other country that went through this
years ago was Japan look how fast Japan
grew from 1969 to 1990 when you see the
numbers all the way to the left look at
that Spike on how the Nikkei 225 stock
market index grew that quickly and
everybody was saying Japan is the way to
go look at the cars they're making look
at all the stuff that they're doing we
were studying them so quickly we were
all studying what Japan was doing
all of a sudden look at the drop from
the peak of 1990. today's 2023 and they
haven't even gotten close to the numbers
they had in 1990. that's 33 years ago
China fears the same exact thing that
happened to Japan is about to happen to
them so what is all this mess leading up
to is it like oh we're the only ones
that knows that this is taking place let
me just say what Millionaires and
billionaires are doing in China right
now here's an article from CNBC try not
to see the world's biggest millionaire
Exodus this year new study shows this is
from a month ago two months ago data
shows that 10 800 High net worth
individuals migrated out of China in
2022 and they're expecting another 13
500 and outside of this article a
Reuters article just came out with this
saying China's Super Rich population
drops as Tech Crackdown Global factors
hurt wealth look at the numbers with
China more than 400 people lost their
billionaire status last year most from
China China lost
229 billionaires from huran Global rich
list in 2023. these are folks that are
no longer making that kind of money
onion they're looking at elsewhere where
can I take my family by the way
sometimes when you leave China you can't
take your money with you it's a very
different kind of a climate to be there
what's the moral of the story here when
the government tries to fabricate the
economy to either cool it off or control
it they do it everywhere we do it in
America matter of fact ours controls
some of the economies around the world
when we try to cool it off or heat it up
when we're like dealing with interest
rates so look when you look at these
numbers the same can be said with a
business when you're growing too fast if
you don't have enough products to fill
in the buyers you're going to cause a
lot of buyers to be sitting two four six
eight weeks to receive the product
they're not going to be happy it's kind
of what's going on over there in China
and then at the same time when you look
at China their population is 1.44
billion but they have 658 million homes
in China so if you say the average house
has three people living there or four
people living there what why do you have
658 million homes when you only have 1.4
it seems like a big number but it's not
a big you have way too many empty places
why produce products and places to live
when you don't have enough people to
want to buy this is all fake economy
this is the fake success that we
experience in America where a lot of
people made a lot of money they bought
all the fancy stuff and then boom it
disappeared on a larger scale China's
going through it right now we're going
to see how they handle this we're going
to see what decisions they make
politically do they get involved do they
kind of stay out of it knowing their
philosophy how it is they feel they want
to control everything they don't want
anything to get out of their hands but
does this also mean they're already a
net negative migration is that going to
Skyrocket with people leaving who knows
but the next 12 24 36 months I would
watch very closely to see what happens
to China if you got value out of this
video give it a thumbs up and subscribe
to the channel I got another video I
want you to watch that has to do with
China's catastrophic mistake they made
years ago when you see these numbers
it's absolutely insane if you've not
seen it click here to watch it take care
everybody bye-bye
thank you
foreign
[Music]